who is Andrew Tate I've heard this man's
name everywhere I have no idea who he is
some people love him some people hate
him some people like me have no idea who
he is so the producers have put together
the very finest Andrew Tate videos this
is truly a fresh reaction I've never
seen anything this man has done and they
gave me a little bio so this is what I
go in knowing Andrew Tate also known as
top G which is my nickname by the way he
and I are gonna have to fight that out
he's a British American 35 year old
former kickboxing champion and reality
TV show star who is now one of the most
controversial and spoken about names on
the internet he is the founder of
Hustler's University an online
mentorship community that shares tips on
cryptocurrency stocks affiliate
marketing and copywriting Tate also owns
multiple other businesses including an
only fans agency oh great okay
goodness only the classiest uh due to
his hot takes and Persona he's been
banned on nearly every single social
media platform including Facebook
Instagram Twitter and YouTube okay so
all I know about this guy
is that he is an athlete
a pimp and too hot for TV take it away
people think you're like sexist because
I say the truth which is
uh women can't fight
men are stronger more true things I I
think another thing I said is I said and
and maybe I'll upset the ladies on the
podcast I hope not but please correct me
if I'm wrong probably I said if I were
to get on a plane an hour to that plane
was to fly into the eye of a hurricane
there was a 50 chance of it crashing I'd
want a male pilot think that males are
better under stress and Under Pressure I
think they're less likely to get
emotional and uh and uh in a life or
death situation that's why they make
better soldiers that doesn't mean I'm
that doesn't make me a misogynist that
doesn't make me sexist that's just true
women are better at other things than
men and I'll sit here and say women are
better at X but I will say that men are
better at why I'm not going to sit and
pretend that that we're all the same
we're not under pressure when your life
is on the line anyone with anyone who's
honest would want a male pilot in said
situation you would not want a female
pilot I don't see the problem with that
what's the problem with that you're
saying men have generally speaking
better spatial reasoning a little cooler
under pressure a little little less
given to
emotional passion that's all true
that is that that's supposed to be a
controversial video
I don't find that controversial all
right next one I wake up every day
excited I'll go do this today I'll go to
this today go to this today
I very much live my life in a frame of
no I have to do this it's very much I
get to do this change your language I
get to go to work today imagine you had
no job be worse right because otherwise
you wouldn't be working so you get to go
to work I have to fix the car at least
you have a car you get to fix your car
most people don't bought one I have to
go get the kids you get to go get the
kids because you have these beautiful
children who love you you understand
people's even their own language is
wrong the world is can be framed maybe
I'm completely crazy maybe I'm full of
[ __ ] like you said maybe I am but the
frames I've installed in my mind are all
beneficial to me so that's not only
unobjectionable that is actually a
positively good way of viewing the world
viewing the world less from a lens of
whining and griping and complaining and
resentment and more through a lens of
gratitude sometimes when I'm here at
this Sweatshop at the daily wire and
we're working 18 hour a day sometimes 20
hour days and I think I'm so tired ah
this and I think well this is a great
job this is all I want to be doing we
ought to be grateful for all in fact we
ought to be grateful for suffering as
well because suffering can be a
sanctifying and edifying experience that
I'm totally on board with that all right
this guy you know when I read that the
guy's a pimp I thought okay this is not
going to be good stuff but there's that
that last clip is is absolutely right
okay next one if you're not gonna have
children what are you gonna do with your
lives if I'm not going to have children
um travel just pursue anything that
makes me happy
um try to make money I love traveling so
I would probably just drink drink
cocktails on a beach okay next
about the same thing like travel focus
on my career my life without children is
vapious and it's inane and it's
pointless and you may sit here and think
that your career matters but the truth
is that your job will fire you out of
whim and not give a second don't give a
solitary and when you're 52 and you're
past it with no grandchildren in a house
by yourself and all your friends have
grandchildren this beautiful life and
you're sitting there by yourself do you
think the fact that you can afford a few
extra Gucci bags is going to genuinely
make you feel happy I was at my
grandmother's 93rd birthday I stood
there and looked at my 93 year old
grandmother and there was a room a whole
room full with maybe 70 people that came
from that one woman isn't that
remarkable that nobody cared about her
career nobody asked what job she did
nobody asked how many times she went to
the club nobody asked if she had time to
go to festivals no you had 70 sentient
beings including myself full of life
from one woman who dedicated herself to
being a mother and a good wife that is
beautiful and if you sit here and
genuinely think that you're going to
work your ass off through your virtual
years and by the age of 54 you're not
going to be suicidal alone with a cat
then you're dumb
women on earth have children and a man
who's paying the bills and their mothers
he's very close to right but he's
missing something he's he's pretty much
as right as you can be
if you're a kind of atheist modernist
materialist capitalist thisist and
thatist generally speaking women who
have children
are much more fulfilled and that's
certainly going to be more edifying than
working at the widget Factory for Mr
McGillicuddy so that you can go to
brunch a little bit more and buy some
more handbags that's totally true but
what that world view leaves out is one
women who can't have kids infertility
big problem and it affects a lot of
people and two women who genuinely are
not called to have kids there are some
women I think who are not called to have
kids and there are other vocations for
them and I use the word vocation
specifically because some some women are
called to religious life I think a woman
who becomes a nun can have a wonderfully
fulfilling life a woman who gives her
entire life to God is going to have a
wonderfully fulfilling life the nuns
that I know are Serene peaceful doing
wonderful things for the world so his
criticism is right what he's really
doing is not even extolling the virtues
of getting married and having kids he's
really just criticizing This Modern
capitalist idea that all that matters is
how much money you can make and how many
widgets you can do spreadsheets for and
how many brunches you have you know how
many Moses you got to down on Sunday and
that's all true that's all worthy of
criticizing but there then he's only
offering the kind of capitalist
alternative at
absent a kind of view of the world that
involves God and that involves Duty and
that involves religion and so you're and
that involves the kind of natural
suffering that goes along in a fallen
World such as infertility he's close I
just suspect that this guy is
view of the world is kind of too narrow
and maybe I haven't heard him speak
about religion but it seems to be
missing the most important element which
is God okay keep going so now you're
going to sit here and you're going to
end your own bloodline all all your
ancestors were out there surrounded by
saber-tooth tigers who had to survive on
the streets out there in caveman days
just to get to the final end where we
have all the medical care and you can
live in a nice warm house for your
selfish ass to say no I don't want kids
I'm too busy in the [ __ ] strip club
or going to [ __ ] Mallorca
to have a pina colada on the beach it's
absolutely insulting to your entire
bloodline there you see exactly what I
just predicted which is that it's this
kind of just modernist like quasi-pagan
almost certainly materialist view of the
world where it's not the reason to have
children is not because man is made in
the image of God and and God tells us to
be fruitful and multiply and to pass on
that love you know the love between a
husband for his wife the love that
becomes so real that it's actually
personified in a child in a way that is
not dissimilar from the love between the
father and the son which is personified
in the Holy Spirit right a love that is
so real that he's an actual person uh
that doesn't factor into what he's
talking about he's just saying you're
disrespecting your ancestors right it's
a kind of
this Pagan ancestor worship which which
I guess is better than the modern
capitalist view the modern kind of you
know just go work at the widget Factory
to make some more money but but
ultimately it's it's not that's not
really fulfilling either keep going all
the times her grandparents went to work
well they didn't feel like it just for
you to exist for your selfish say no me
and my passions and my dreams and my
drawings on my Instagram page is worth
more than ever having children you're a
selfish
that you should all have kids obviously
he could probably probably clean up the
language around women I just generally
speaking don't think it's great to talk
like a sailor in mixed company call me
old-fashioned but I just don't think
that's very gentlemanly but the point
he's making is
it's more correct than incorrect
it's just missing the most important
part which is
God and and when you
when you take God out of the equation
you can go down some pretty weird weird
Trails okay next one if I understood
what you said that if a guy and a girl
is dating and a girl does only fans she
owes him a cut no 100 girl
100 he is his girl
what was that up doing your property
it's not about being properties about
the fact that she belongs to him and the
intimate parts of her body belong to him
because they're in a relationship and if
she wants to sell those he has a stake
in those parts of her body so so it's
reverse uh male porn star owes the woman
I don't know because I think the women
belong to the man I think the woman
that's inherently where you get called
sexist no it's not well you can you can
call me sexist if you you want but if
you look at marriage it's the bride's
father who gives her away there it is
see this is where the guy falls apart
because he's making this very stupid
point that if a man and a woman are
dating the man has the right to be her
pimp and take money from her
prostituting herself
and his his reasoning for this is that
the woman belongs to the man and then
what's the example he uses he says well
look at a marriage
right in a marriage it's not exactly
that the woman belongs to the man or
that the man belongs to the woman but
the man and the woman leave their
parents and they come together and they
become one flesh and what God is United
no man
ought to separate and man is the head of
woman as Christ is the head of his
church so yes there there is a
leadership role for the man within the
the marriage not within this lame I'm in
a relationship I'm oh yeah I'm in a
modern relationship where the man
basically is just some completely
unaccountable degenerate some just
shiesty disgusting street urchin some
kind of pimp you know and and he says
well no I'm in a relationship with you
so that so you belong to me and I I get
to have all the Privileges that a
husband would have with his right but
with his wife but you get none of the
rights that a wife has with her husband
and so that's just ridiculous I mean
that's just completely wrong and and
degenerate and uh and really you know
very disgusting he's the reason it's
appealing is because it seems in a way
like it it's sort of partaking of a more
traditional view of marriage except he's
taking the marriage out of it see you're
losing the entire essence of the thing
and that's why it sounds skeezy which it
is so is slavery yeah no but I gotta
guess as somebody who's Multicultural
and everything that that certainly is a
tradition that does not apply everywhere
the woman is always given over to the
man read them read the Bible read the
Quran read you can go to the walking
down the aisle no chance there's
definitely there's like African cultures
where they don't do that I'm sure there
are some obscure tribes somewhere I mean
I can't say I'm not a professional but
you you get it you seem like a virgin
yeah you seem like a smart guy you're
saying a woman is the property of a man
if they're dating I'm not saying they're
appropriate I'm saying they're given to
the man and they belong to the man it
doesn't mean they're pure property
without emotion it means they're living
they're given to the man they take the
man's name
right there yeah it takes the man's name
in marriage
not in a relationship
and when you're in a marriage the the
love between a husband and a wife is
supposed to be true love a love that is
that is really willing the good of the
other person and especially within a
marriage willing the good of the other
person because the other person is part
of your flesh you join together and
become one flesh whereas what he's
talking about which is basically a pimp
and a hooker that's not love that's not
someone willing the good of the other
that's that's someone trying to consume
the other like like dessert you know
that's that's someone just trying to use
the other person if C.S Lewis describes
this in the screw tape letters
that the kind of Desire that that we
ought to have for one another as human
beings
the kind of Desire that we ought to have
for our spouse
is one of true love and self-sacrifice
but the that's the love that God has for
us God sacrifices himself for us he
loves us so much he he loves us so much
that he gives his only begotten son that
whoever believes in him will not perish
but may have everlasting life the kind
of uh desire that demons have for us is
the desire that I have for a
cheeseburger at lunchtime it's a desire
just to consume and satiate your own
personal appetites and in your lowest
kinds of desires and and he's conflating
the two but the two couldn't possibly be
more different you're like if she's on
only fans the guy owns those parts so he
gets a cut well those parts are intimate
right that's the whole point of her
being his yeah but you didn't do reverse
they're not intimate if you're
prostituting your girlfriend out on only
fans then it's not it then it's then you
are you are totally undermining
those parts as intimate right and you're
making that a sort of public commodity
and so any claim that you might have
however dubious or ridiculous you're
you're relinquishing that when you turn
someone that you were supposed to love
into basically just a a cash cow a kind
of slab of meat so that you can I don't
know go
get get a little bit more money if a
male porn star does it he doesn't owe
the girl a cup correct because she
because he doesn't belong to her she
still belongs to him yeah little little
incoherent from Mr Tate but I'm not
surprised because he owns an only fans
agency so he he does this right he is a
pimp and he sells these women and uses
them like like meat and and just as sort
of uh
taking a human being and just degrading
her into nothing but the material and
flesh to prey on addicted men and take
money from both of them so that he can I
don't know why he can just buy more
stuff and try to satisfy his own
material cravings
it's it's it's clear here unlike in some
of the other videos where he's talking
about things that he doesn't have a
financial stake in you know talking
about things like hey when you wake up
in the morning be grateful you know he
doesn't make he doesn't lose money or
make money on on that advice so he gives
advice that's a little bit better but on
this one he's engaged in a very depraved
and exploitative sort of action and so
he's trying to defend it with absolutely
incoherent kind of arguments all right
next one you've also said that you could
have multiple partners but a female that
was with you couldn't also have multiple
partners well a woman could say that
same thing if she decided she could say
I can sleep with multiple men but my men
can't sleep with multiple women if she
so Jews we're all free individuals right
yeah but you don't you wouldn't agree if
a woman said that I would personally
find that revolting correct but there
are women who find well I say revolting
so you're not telling other people what
to think you're just saying how you
think I think if a man is not sexually
exclusive it's not the same as if a
woman is because with a woman you have
the paternity issue with a man you don't
have a paternity issue if I have three
girlfriends and they all get pregnant we
know who the mother and who the father
is if you have one woman and three men
you don't know who even the parents are
she got pregnant yeah you could
definitely figure that out DNA tests are
pretty accessible nowadays so I said
science could step in and fix it but
that doesn't mean it's not Haram and
against the will of God look read the
Bible every single man had multiple
wives not single woman had multiple
husbands it's against the will of God
it's disgusting in the eyes right there
I think his biblical exegesis is a
little bit weak here the point he's
making though that it's it's different
for a man than it is for a woman that's
absolutely true and why is it different
because of the possibility of pregnancy
absolutely true what he says about uh
you know people in the Bible having
multiple wives in the Old Testament
that is true
God doesn't approve of that in fact when
the men take multiple wives things go
really really bad you see this
throughout the Book of Genesis
when the men fail to trust in God's plan
and start to try to take matters into
their own hands let's say for instance
man can't have a child
starts to you know sleep with the the
wife's handmaiden or whatever things
start to go really really bad and it
leads to millennia-long problems for
Humanity so he's observing yes men do
have these multiple wives in the Old
Testament what he doesn't point out is
that is that is not the will of God
because we know that from the beginning
God created man male and female created
he them and they are meant to come
together in a Union One Man and one wife
and then you see this reiterated by
Christ in the New Testament when he
defines marriage there are very few
institutions that that Christ defines
explicitly in the Bible but he does
define marriage in this way and so you
know probably this guy is not
particularly familiar with the Bible he
should brush up on that because really
his argument is is a very modernist
liberal sort of argument yeah well
listen if a man wants to do something
and the woman consents to that then
consent is all that matters and yeah
maybe the women can want to kind of [ __ ]
it up too and if the man consents to it
it's fine but no consent is not all that
matters it's not and espec when we're
describing virtue when we're trying to
figure out what is good and what is bad
consent isn't even isn't even the top
Criterion to consider we actually share
many of our feelings of revulsion
against certain things like people going
out and slutting it up all the time we
feel we would have feel jealousy if any
of our spouses did that sort of thing so
the question has to be why is that not
just wow that's a weird Quirk that we
all are revolted by that no why are we
revolted by that because that's bad well
if it's bad then you shouldn't do it I
don't believe in depression don't
message me about depression because I
don't believe in it if you're asleep and
you're a bat in the middle of the night
and you hear a noise and you believe in
ghosts now you're afraid but if you
don't believe in ghosts ah it's the wind
then you go back to Sea you give the
ghosts Power by believing in them your
house is only haunted if you believe in
ghosts belief is a powerful thing how to
stand in front of you and I were to tell
you but I could punch you as hard as I
can in your sternum and I could fracture
it and send a splinter into your heart
would you allow me to try
you wouldn't because you know I believe
I can I believe I can hurt any man on
the planet and that's why people are
afraid of you and you believe depression
is a crippling disease and that's why
you're afraid of it so he gets to his
point at the end which is that for a lot
of people uh depression is not this
permanent State of Affairs but it's it's
a more psychological than say physical
you know a chemical imbalance in the
brain or whatever for a lot of people I
think they would snap out of depression
if they took account of their spiritual
and psychological life and made changes
to their life I think that would fix a
lot of the widespread depression that
you see in the country but his point on
ghosts is not correct the existence or
non-existence of ghosts does not hinge
on whether or not you believe in them I
I think ghosts are real I think that
pretty much everyone throughout all of
human history has seen ghosts you ever
go to a dinner party my friend Andrew
Cleveland has this trick he goes he asks
hey says hey you ever seen a ghost
many if not most people
will say yeah you know actually actually
I did see a ghost there's a ghost in the
Bible when when Saul is talking to the
witch of Endor
she summons the ghost of Samuel so yeah
I think there are ghosts one thing he
says there is definitely not true he
says if you believe in ghosts and you
say I think there's a ghost in my house
you're going to be afraid but if you
don't believe in ghosts you're going to
say oh it's just the wind and you won't
worry about it in my experience it's
exactly the opposite I do believe that
ghosts exist I'm not afraid of ghosts
I'm not afraid of ghosts because I'm a
Christian and I'm I put much more faith
in God than I do in disembodied spirits
and ghosts and demons and anything like
that one of the only times I saw my dad
ever get arrested was at a barbecue well
some woman was walking down the street
uh it's hard to explain where he lived
in in Elkhart Indiana but we're living
there and all the back Gardens were open
this one was looking along she goes and
we're having a barbecue and she goes
have you seen my cat my dad said would
you recognize it barbecued and just a
horror on her face anyway she walked off
she called the police the police
officers came my dad got an argument a
few times because he was drunk and he
got arrested only a cat owning [ __ ]
would complain to the police about
[ __ ] joke fine you're upset you lost
your cat Fair it off yeah the joke maybe
a little bit you know risque who calls
the police on a [ __ ] joke cat owners
cat owners are liberals
at owners or kids that is mostly true
I'm not saying it's without exception or
it's not without exception rather but
exceptions prove rules
I I think he's right about the cats do
you agree that we are biologically
different or do you think you're as
strong as men no of course not okay well
there you go then so there we go so we
already have a violence you're the
protector and I'm like the person no we
have a biological difference and if you
have a certain biology wouldn't you
agree that your biology lends to your
mentality right okay so we have a
different biology and a different
mentality do you agree yeah okay so
we're not equal
Doug for the men what do you guys
consider a high-valued man is it looks
is it money or is it both okay it's a
few things right so there's there's the
obvious evolutionary triggers the
easiest way to be a high value man is a
man who's capable of violence if we look
at it from a biological trigger it
doesn't matter if he's got muscles or
he's big or he's tall whatever women
understand from a biological perspective
they like a man who can fight yeah it
doesn't matter if your man had money a
Ferrari everything but if you knew for a
fact if any dude stepped to him he'd get
sparked you wouldn't want him right so
that's the first thing no but no yeah
you need a mannequin fight but but
really truly to answer your question I
think that the true marker of a high
value man is a man who could say no to
[ __ ] and I mean this on a genuine level
here's the problem here's the problem
you girls don't understand all the lower
level dudes you say I don't want a high
value man who cheats if you've got a
lower value guy he'll cheat up with
anybody he'll [ __ ] anything he has no
choice if you get high value guy at
least he has the option to say no to
something there's a lot of Truth in that
last point that he made and I'm gonna
try to clean it up maybe rewrite it a
little bit he's saying that the greatest
marker of a high value man is that he
can say no to the ladies that is
obviously true what he's saying is that
the high value man is in control of his
base passions that man has two Wills
that exist simultaneous women have that
too I'm saying man in the general sense
the lower will which is the appetite
that's the passion that's just when you
want to eat the cookies in the cookie
jar and then the higher will which is
the rational will which tells you uh no
actually if I eat all the cookies in the
cookie jar I'm gonna have a tummy ache
so I'm not going to do that and the
traditional way of understanding this
the rational will the higher will
mediates between the lower will the
appetite and the Divine will which is
perfect and so yes a high value man will
be in a great command and he will follow
his rational will and he will subdue his
passions absolutely true the irony of
him talking in this way is that he's
he's describing a kind of animalistic
world where it's just about doing kind
of random violence right it's not things
are not really particularly rational or
orderly and then you especially see this
in the way he's talking about women and
saying that women are are less than man
and because yeah it's true obviously
there are physical differences between
men and women
and there there are non-physical
differences between men and women too
but there is a an essential spiritual
equality between men and women to use
this kind of pagan almost animalistic
language well you know you've got this
kind of lower value and all this that
that to me doesn't it just Rings like
the way you would talk about an animal
but but man is not merely an animal
we're made in the image and likeness of
God so we are corporeal we have bodies
but we also have reason and intellect
and will and so we can we can talk about
the very fact we can talk about things
is proof of this I have an argument with
a feminist and she was saying that we
need to teach men not to read and I said
my dear I love how idealistic you are
but I am realistic men are already
taught not to read she's like no they
need to we need to go and change
language at school and rewrite history
and do all the [ __ ] they're trying to do
to make men weak because they think that
weak men don't rape which is another
argument I want to come back to because
weak men are the most dangerous men on
the planet let's talk about that later
true but I said no people already
understand that rape is wrong
unfortunately human nature some people
don't care about doing wrong things we
should teach people not to steal but
they still steal would you agree that
everyone says don't steal the Bible says
don't steal the Quran says don't steal
schools say don't steal everyone says
don't steal people still steal so if I
were to take a million dollars in cash
and walk down the street at night in the
worst part of town holding it to a
degree I would have some responsibility
when I got robbed the police would come
and say why did you do that people would
say Andrew why did you do that you have
to protect yourself from things you
can't just rely on the ideological hope
that others other people in the world
are going to be perfect and infallible
or that the law is going to prevent it
you have to say no I can't walk through
the ghetto at two in the morning with a
million dollars in cash I take personal
responsibility she agreed I said then by
extension would you agree that the
smartest single woman can do to prevent
rape is not to sit here on a podcast and
try and change the way men think and
talk about your [ __ ] but to take
some degree of personal responsibility
and not put yourself in dangerous
situations obviously 100 True every
every syllable he entered there is
obviously correct is that it that's all
the undertape videos okay
this guy I'm gonna be
as charitable first of all the first
thing you should do is shut down his
only fans business and stop being a pimp
and stop using women like they're just
flesh and selling their flesh so that
you can have a few more dollars don't do
that but I'm I'm saying this genuinely
with a spirit of Charity because I think
his heart is almost in the right place I
think he's searching after something
that is true that is true and he's just
been raised in this decadent stupid
materialist culture you're on the right
track you've just gotta you've just got
to go further he recognizes that the
kind of modern lib culture is stupid and
wrong and and leading people to
miserably misery in all sorts of
Misfortune but he he still wants to
partake of that modern lib culture this
emphasis on consent ignoring the kind of
transcendent moral order this using
people just for their body to satiate
your own base desires which he knows and
he's actually said are the the stuff of
low status low value men and actually
higher value men are able to discipline
themselves well discipline yourself
according to what discipline yourself
according to the moral order according
to your just subjective preferences on
what the moral order should be no course
not that just leads you right back to
the first place it's got to be an
objective moral order that is outside of
you that he keeps referencing the Bible
in the Quran well look to the holy book
pal because you you see it all laid out
there you really should not stand in the
middle of the road here okay if you
stand in the middle of the road you're
gonna get hit by a truck so either just
live the life of a kind of modern demon
and and you know an incarnate demon and
pursue whatever stupid base desires you
want and at least you're being honest
about that you're already doing that
you're just not being honest with
yourself about it or go all the way and
actually follow your ideas to their
logical conclusion and have them not
only change the ideas that you're
espousing and make them much more
coherent but have them change your
behavior as well because
salvation hinges on the flesh my friend
and so you judge the tree by its fruit
and so we're going to see how how you
are living your life and uh you know
I'll believe that you follow these ideas
to their logical conclusion when you
give up the freaking only fans agency
he's on the right track but he's got to
go much much further counters are
liberals cat owners believe in hate
speech cat owners are Democrats cat
owners